our summit today reconfirms the  importance of our strategic partnership  [Music]  the Republic of Korea is a solid  like-minded reliable and committed  partner in Asia today we send a strong  message about our shared values and  principles and our commitment to the  rules-based international order in the  face of serious global challenges in  particular to the nuclear  non-proliferation regime but also  climate change and the world's many  conflicts we have to work together in  the United Nations and as well to find  common responses president one I am  happy to have you as a close partner in  our shared efforts  [Music]